[Music]
Disney keeps ramping up the hype for
descendants three by drip-feeding us
short trailers sneak peeks and music
videos did you notice all of the little
details that are full of clues about the
upcoming movie but these friendships
will be tested some will Bend summer
break villain signs in a meet Celia
trailer we see a celebration scene in
auradon some of the partygoers are
holding up signs there's the front of a
car with the license plate Deville for
Carlos next to that is the genies lamp
for J then there's a purple dragon head
for now and then a hook with a clock
could it be for the Smee twins squeaky
and squirmy four for Harry hook on the
other side there's a sign that's tricky
to decipher next to that there's a red
heart for Evie and a skull and a top hat
for Celia the final sign looks like
Ursula shell necklace which could be for
uma what do they all mean looking at the
partygoers clothes they look like a mix
of V case and a case it's so intriguing
all the BK's are going to our don it
might well be that all the b ches have
escaped from the Isle for this party let
us explain in the VK day is coming
trailer we get a close look at the our
dog park application form for the
villain kids
we're told that only 4 v Ches will be
chosen but if you look real close at the
forum you'll discover a snippet of info
that most people missed look right at
the bottom it says in time all of you
will join us
stelios makeup did you notice those
white dots and exclamation points
painted around Celia's eyes they're
totally reminiscent of the makeup her
sister Freddy veselija wears could that
be a clue about the links between the
sisters there's chatter amongst fans
about why Freddy isn't in descendants 3
after all we've already been introduced
to her in the wicked world animated
shorts and Melissa de la Cruz as
descendants novels so why do they choose
to give dr. Faso via a different
daughter perhaps Celia striking makeup
is a nod to her sister Disney's dress
but made me dizzy and dissonance - she
was wearing an apron but in the sneak
peeks for the third movie Disney's been
given a brand new outfit and when we got
a good look at it in the meet Celia
trailer it totally reminded us of a
certain Princess Anna from frozen
specifically the gown on awareness for
Elsa's coronation check out what we mean
as
watch dizzy skipping through a tunnel
with Celia that particular shade of
greens the black background and the
flowers are so on a style do you think
this has any hidden meaning
Celia slack Celia certainly got that
evil laugh down pat we heard at the end
of both of her trailers but does it
remind you of anyone we can't help but
think it sounds exactly like Loomis evil
laugh could it be the same laughs is it
hinting at a link between uma and Celia
after all not all evil laughs sound like
that we only have to listen to Cameron
voice dove Cameron booboo Stewart little
hope and Sophia Carson's attempts at an
evil laugh to realize that the Do Not
Disturb sign in the meet celia trailer
we see her waiting for customers in her
fortune-telling area did you notice the
words written on the door in the
background they spell out ha the wrong J
this translates as do not bother or do
not disturb we assume it's the door into
dr. facile ears office what language is
this sign written it's Haitian Creole
that's a French base language spoken on
the islands of Haiti could that give a
clue about dr. facile ears origins
that's intriguing as his past is mostly
unknown where to look for new vks we're
dying to find out who the newest B case
will be and there might actually be a
telling clue and mouth darkness trailer
there's a blink and you'll miss it
moments in the scene when Ben and mal
are standing on the balcony
this team pops up again and the uma is
back trailer look real close in the
bottom right hand corner you'll see what
looks like dizzy standing with sneeze
twins squeaky and squirmy their red
beanie hats and long blonde hair make
them stand out in the crowd if these new
V K's are in the crowd could the others
be there to the stowaway in the meet
hades trailer we see four main b ches
and then looking shocked they rush out
of the purple car on the Isle and see
Hades making a hole in the barrier but
what's really intriguing is that extra
person look just behind evey and you'll
see a red beanie hat the person is so
small you can't see their face over the
car door but why is he with Ben mal J
Carlos and Evie was he
go away and where's the other twin in
the mystery trailer we see both twins
under the power of the sleeping spell
did one of them wake up yeah well that's
wonderful news she got a flat tire in
Sherwood Forest and she wants me to go
fix it
the red beanie those red beanies really
stand out and it's not just the twins
who wear them we spotted another one and
the uma is back trailer there's a crowd
of UK's gathering around as mal and then
get into the purple car on the Isle take
a look at the VK right behind then he's
wearing a red beanie and a denim outfit
it looks like he's closing the car door
after Ben that suggests he's not getting
in the car too so who is he could it be
Smee himself
waving goodbye to his sons as they leave
the isle we can't wait to find out which
of these things did you notice and which
ones flew right over your head tell us
in the comments please give this video a
big thumbs up and subscribe to our
channel for more great videos like this
one thanks for watching the things we'll
see you soon
[Music]